denn dänemark spanien norwegen israel
großbritannien immer mehr länder auf der
welt beenden ihre corona maßnahmen in
deutschland hingegen erklärte
gesundheitsminister die diskussion über
lockerungen sei fehl am platz in ganz
europa gilt weit eine genesenen status
sechs monate sagen in deutschland
erklärte das lka er gilt nur drei
minuten und auch bei der impfpflicht
gerät deutschland zunehmend in eine
isolation die allgemeine impfpflicht
gibt es nur in einem land in europa
nämlich in österreich in den anderen
ländern ist sie noch nicht mal ein thema
und ich fordere schluss mit diesem
deutschen corona sonderweg ja die ampel
macht eine bessere pandemie politik als
die vorgängerregierung ich glaube unter
merkel werden wir alle seit weihnachten
im lockdown das ist gut dass wir das
verhindert haben aber das reicht nicht
mehr corona verändert die lage und
deswegen muss sich auch die politik
verändern wir müssen wir schrittweise
zurück in die normalität andere länder
können das und ich glaube wir können das
auch erich den interessanten punkt
deutscher sonderweg dass es gibt sie in
vielen politischen bereichen deutschland
war auch zu beginn der pandemie da
meiner auffassung auf einem sonderweg da
hatte man nämlich den eindruck das
ausland hat schon maßnahmen ergriffen
die gene konzept begabt am flughafen
beispielsweise bei uns war nix dahinter
plötzlich mal irgendwie am flughafen mal
so ein plakat und da gibt es neuartige
corona virus aus wo an oder so um hat
sich gefragt wann wachen wir auf wann
ergreifen wir maßnahmen jetzt sind wir
in diesem modus dass wir maßnahmen haben
und jetzt kommen wir davon aber nicht
wieder runter dass das verstehe ich
nicht also hatte immerhin war erst spät
dran sozusagen sich an die neue realität
anzupassen jetzt sind wir sozusagen an
corona irgendwie angepasst jetzt
schaffen wir es aber nicht wieder nicht
davon runter zu kommen weil wir uns an
die an die veränderte realität auch
nicht anpassen offensichtlich nämlich
dass das omikron die omikron variante ja
gott sei dank nicht so schlimm ist und
milde verläufe macht und bei vielen nur
an schnupfen teilweise ja so auch wenn
wir wenn wir gucken in den 223 fälle
hatte deutschland mit die strengsten
maßnahmen überhaupt in europa kein land
sonst hat solange die schulen
geschlossen miller gesprochen die
materialschäden für schülerinnen und
schüler an dramatisch das heißt wir
haben immer wieder einen besonders
harten weg gewählt wie wir jetzt merken
war das noch nicht mal der
erfolgreichste kurs und wir gucken
welche schäden
verhindert worden und ich glaube jetzt
ist es dringend an der zeit dass wir
auch die politik auf die neue situation
anpassen omikron ist eben anders als
delta und andere länder haben das früher
verstanden als wir brauchen wir einen
film day hagen so wie es beispielsweise
auch dänemark in der vergangenen woche
ein zweites mal durchgeführt hat und
exerziert wir müssen natürlich das ziel
haben zurück zur normalität zu kommen ob
das an einem tag basiert oder ob man das
schrittweise macht ich glaube das muss
man dann abwägen aber das ziel kann ja
nicht sein dass wir diese maßnahmen
jetzt mehr weiter führen dass wir jetzt
das haben gesagt in jeder grippewelle
möglicherweise unsere impf ausweise
vorzeigen wenn wir ins restaurant gehen
dass wir zugangsbeschränkungen machen in
kultur sport und anderen veranstaltungen
soll das ziel muss sein ich möchte dass
wenn corona ruhmes und nicht in dem
sinne dass verschwindet wird nicht
verschwinden wir müssen da mit dem virus
zu leben oder wenn die gefahr der
überforderung des gesundheitssystems
vorbei ist dann möchte ich dass wir
wieder genau so leben wie wir das vor
corona getan haben ich hab den
bundeskanzler mitgebrachte nächste woche
ist ja wieder einen bundesländer gipfel
ein corona gipfel morgen mittwoch in
einer woche und haben das thema frieden
beckrath angesprochen ich wollte einmal
die runde frage fällt auch sehr alt
ihrem bundeskanzler brauchen freedom day
was muss passieren am kommenden mittwoch
beim und länder gipfel ich bin haben sie
die chance ist den kanzler direkt zu
sagen völlig einig mit martin hagen dass
wir wieder zurück zur normalität müssen
aber vielleicht nicht nächste woche wie
gesagt die impfquote bei uns ist
wesentlich schlechter als in den ländern
die jetzt in freedom day haben und darum
und darum müssen wir das ganz ganz genau
abwägen okay was muss passieren
antwort an den kanzler jetzt einmal was
bloß nächsten mittwoch auf dem bund
länder gipfel passieren welche maßnahmen
müssen gelockert werden vielleicht sogar
weg dann gebe ich jetzt keine ratschläge
an olaf scholz ist müssen die
entscheiden die wirkt die verantwortung
haben der bundestag beschäftigt sich
wieder mehr märz damit ob wir das
infektionsschutzgesetz verlängern mit
diesen maßnahmen wir sagen nein wir
bewerten das anders dann sind diese
maßnahmen alle nicht mehr möglich dafür
braucht die gesetzliche ermächtigung und
bei der impfpflicht sehen sie ja auch
die abgeordneten das ernst wenn sie die
umfragen sehen auch der welt letzte
woche dass die leute sehr differenziert
sich hier meinung machen darüber welche
anträge auf dem tisch liegen also wie
wir corona bekämpfen möchten und welche
jetzt welchem antrag sie sich dann auch
zustimmen möchten deshalb nehme ich an
meine kollegen und ich wir betrachten
das differenziert aber wir
wir lockern und wir nehmen maßnahmen weg
wenn es noch zeit ist frau rehbein sie
sitzen nicht im bundestag hat trotzdem
die chance dem bundeskanzler jetzt
einmal zu sagen was muss mittwoch in
einer woche passieren auf dem geländer
gipfel also ich sehe ich so als nicht
politikerin und als normale bürgerin
unternehmerin des landes habe ich
mittlerweile seit zwei jahren das gefühl
dass die politiker sich gar nicht mehr
trauen ich habe mal wieder die
verantwortung haben ist übernimmt doch
gar keiner verantwortung das gefühl
kommt auf das keiner mehr traut sich was
zu ändern weil es haben wir zwei jahre
lang der bevölkerung so viel zugemutet
und so viele tolle regeln aufgestellt
die alle in die völlig im sande
verlaufen wenig befolgt werden können
von wird von land zu land bundeslands
wurde auch noch unterschiedlich sind und
ihr gibt beschleicht ein so das gefühl
dass das das land überhaupt gar keine
richtige für mehr hat dass wir so dahin
plätschern und verantwortung übernehmen
tut keiner sondern wir machen einfach so
weiter wie es ist weil also wieder voll
auf scholl würde ich als unternehmerin
mein unternehmen so für in welchen
insolvent wie wir teilweise hier das
land führen
sebastian du bist politischer beobachter
als bild redakteur für politik und
wirtschaft von daher deine botschaft ein
kanzler ich würde aber sagen herr
scheibe drücken sie denn überhaupt dass
die maßnahmen noch gelten es müsste ja
ein automatismus sein dass wenn keine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems mehr
droht wenn wir jetzt auch sehr viel mehr
wissen über krone als vor zwei jahren
das dann solche maßnahmen fallen das ist
eigentlich unser gutes recht ich möchte
wissen warum er sich raus nimmt unser
recht auf unsere freiheit einzuschränken
heran wann muss der früh in beckum man
sollte olaf scholz hinaus rufen olaf
scholz braucht den frieden unter
überhaupt nicht aus zu rufen die krone
politik wird maßgeblich in den ländern
bestimmt wir haben eine
infektionsschutzgesetz dass die ampel
gemacht hat dass den ländern ein
instrumentenkasten zur verfügung
gestellt den können sie ausschöpfen sie
müssen die nicht ausschöpfen und zum
beispiel in bayern hat man bisher und
besonders strenge regeln wir hatten eine
sperrstunde um 22 uhr die wird jetzt
abgeschafft nicht durch olaf scholz
sondern durch die bayerische regierung
und so sollte jedes bundesland schauen
wo sie wieder mehr freiheit ermöglichen
können dann die situation gibt das
momentan ist es überfällig sie kommen
aus bayern frau rehbein ist überfällig
dass dort gehandelt wird oder steigen
sie anders gefragt eigentlich noch durch
man hat mal den eindruck nein bayern
prescht vor in die eine richtung da
wieder die an richtung ich habe ich muss
gestehen ich hatte es heute schon
erzählt ich bin jetzt frischmann erst
mal wieder essen wir gerne den letzten
samstag duellieren und herzlich danke 22
uhr kam der wirt und sagte müssen gehen
sie müssen gehen und hab ich gedacht ich
hab das verbrauche ich sowieso was jetzt
gemacht und ich hatte das gar nicht mehr
auf dem schirm des hätten schwerer
stunde waren ja bis 22 uhr wie ein
kleines dünnes mädchen wirst du nach
hause geschickt als wenn ich keine
einfache lebende von demokratie wo ist
da die demokratie wie die kann man das
überhaupt noch rechtfertigen ich fühle
mich so was von bevormundet dass sie um
22 uhr nach hause geschickt werde und
ich kann das als bürgerin überhaupt
nicht mehr akzeptieren mit den jetzigen
ich kann ich verstehe sie dass sie
vielleicht einen überblick verloren
haben also meine lehre aus der pandemie
wäre werden wir mal wieder so eine
pandemie haben die führung durch
bundesebene ich finde es auf deren es
eben nicht zu suchen für das ganze land
einheitliche regeln dann weiß man auch
wenn die aufhören die in kraft gesetzt
werden wenn die außer kraft treten und
das ist eine sache die müssen wir uns
anschauen also jeder der eigentlich
führung ein bisschen versteht der weiß
es bringt nichts wenn 16 leute führen
und dann muss eben einer führen muss
auch einer die verantwortung und werde
in sachsen hat mir die entscheidung sehr
wenn sie sagen franco diktatur aber wenn
ich jemanden in das tal wenn fälle in
sachsen bei unter 70 prozent ist in
bremen aber bei deutlich über 90 prozent
dann soll trotzdem in sachsen und bremen
die gleichen bedingungen die gleichen
corona maßnahmen greifen das machen
andere länder ja auch bei denen sie uns
sonst ja auch so gerne vergleichen ich
finde es auf jeden fall eine größere
nachvollziehbarkeit regeln welche regel
gilt hier jetzt und nicht jeder
landkreis entscheidet wie es am anfang
jahr hat mir dass jeder landkreis quasi
die korona maßnahmen hat noch
nachgeschärft hatte glück da
widersprechen überzeugter föderalist und
ich glaube dass es sich durchaus bewährt
hat dass wir in deutschland auch
unterschiedliche regeln hatten wir haben
dadurch auch gesehen welche regeln
wirken und welche nicht schon sie bayern
hatte fast durchgehend die strengsten
regeln sie hatten aber meistens die
schlechtesten zahlen das heißt wir
konnten sehen dass solche sachen wie
diese bayerische ausgangssperre oder
jetzt die krone sperrstunde 22 uhr dass
die eben nicht geholfen haben und wir
haben gesehen dass andere länder wie zum
beispiel die länder wo die fdp
gesundheitsminister stellt schleswig
holstein mit milderen regeln bessere
ergebnisse gebracht haben und deswegen
glaube ich brauche wieder keinen
zentralismus und wir brauchen insgesamt
einfach wieder mehr augenmaß in dieser
kurve politik ist eigentlich aus ihrer
sicht die allgemeine impfpflicht fast
schon tot wenn wir sie kommen aus bayern
sehen was der bayerische
ministerpräsident gestern angekündigt
hatte er gesagt hat dass die impfpflicht
für pfleger für ärzte erst mal de facto
ausgesetzt wird also nicht umgesetzt
werden soll dann ist ja die große frage
was passiert eigentlich mit der
allgemeinen wehrpflicht
der witz ist ja markus söder war der
große befürworter der einrichtungs
bezogenen impfpflicht jetzt ist sie da
jetzt sagt da wir setzen sie nicht um
aber gleichzeitig fordert er dass auf
bundesebene eine allgemeine impfpflicht
für alle kommen muss ich halte es für
ein totes pferd ich glaube dass es mit
der nikon variante nicht mehr zu
rechtfertigen ist denn wir wissen ja
dass wir das virus nicht ausrotten
werden weil geimpfte und ungeimpfte
beide das virus auch weiter übertragen
können das heißt mit dem ziel einer
ausrottung der krankheit kann man sowas
nicht begründen und wir haben momentan
auch nicht die befürchtung dass die
kliniken überlastet werden und wenn wir
die befürchtung hätten dann wäre das
auch kein argument für eine allgemeine
impfpflicht weil er die klinik nicht
durch die 18 20 30 40 jährige überlastet
werden sondern insbesondere durch die
über 60 über 70-jährigen das heißt damit
könnte man allenfalls eine
altersabhängige impfpflicht begründen
ich glaube aber dass das thema impfen
ich generell vom tisch sollte ich glaube
wir brauchen das nicht wir haben
übrigens auch bei den älteren neben
futter von 90 prozent ist nicht so dass
wir da lauter umgebung hätten also sehr
herald martinhagen jetzt im bundestag
dann würde er vehement gegen die
allgemeine impfpflicht auch
argumentieren debatte die ja offenbar
nächste woche stattfinden soll xbox die
erste lesung geht das ganze gesetz im
ausschuss wird dort fachlich diskutiert
aber wir wissen ja noch gar nicht welche
vorschläge vorliegen haben meine drei
vorschläge die parteiübergreifend
vorliegen oder die hirten noch von der
afg okay und es sind noch zwei weitere
zu erwarten nächste woche heißt wir
haben dann sechs vorschläge nachdem für
die jeder abgeordnete stimmen kann und
von denen einer die mehrheit auf sich
vereinen muss wird noch spannend aber es
ist doch eigentlich schon rohrkrepierer
diese allgemein empfiehlt oder nicht das
würde ich sagen wenn die abstimmung
gelaufen dass wir haben den die debatte
ja noch gar nicht geführt die ist nicht
zu ende geführt aber wie wollen sie eine
allgemeine impfpflicht denn eigentlich
argumentieren wenn man eigentlich immer
nur hinterher impft also wenn man jetzt
ein impfstoff hat beispielsweise der
gegen die data variante hilft aber gar
nicht promikon wenn man dann im herbst
impft gegen beispielsweise die omikron
variante die aber dann im herbst gar
nicht mehr existiert sondern überlagert
ist ich sage jetzt mal von einer
englischen variante wie auch immer ich
habe auch gar nicht für die eine andere
variante gesprochen ich bin mir
meinungen dann wenn noch nicht mal alle
vorschläge auf den tisch legen werde ich
mich nicht hinstellen und sagen ich bin
vor lernte variante a b oder c das wäre
unfair da kommen noch 2 3 und dann werde
ich entscheiden wie ich abstimmen hat
weiß ich noch nicht wir sollten übrigens
nicht sagen die impfung hilft nicht
gegen omikron also sie hilft deren
verlauf ja es ist ein sehr guter
eigenschutz die impfung aber sie hilft
eben nicht oder sie schützt nicht davor
dass man sich infiziert sich schützt
nicht davor dass man das virus weiter
gibt und das ist der punkt damit ist
auch die impfpflicht eigentlich nicht
mehr nicht begründen sicherlich auch
nicht vor erkrankungen also wir haben
natürlich auch genug geimpfte die auch
erkranken und auch immer noch einen
schweren verlauf haben und da muss man
sich auch wirklich sagen in wie weit
kann ich in der bevölkerung dann zumuten
impfpflicht zu haben für eine impfung
die eben nicht verhindert die nicht
ausreichend wirklich schützt so was zu
auf zu doktor ihren ist es am ende des
tages finde ich schon schwierig